Today's Monday Minute is: "Get out of the office!"
I got a great email from my video producer, Christina,
hey, Christina! (she's watching);
who reminded me that, you know, if all you need is an internet connection and a laptop, to encourage...
people to get out of the office. And it's true, you can get stuck in rut, doing the same thing in the same...
environment and you can shake things up, get new creativity, get new ideas, get new motivation...
new energy by just getting out of your office!
If you could work from a laptop, go work in the garden one day.
If all you need is an internet connection, go to a Starbucks, go to a library.
Just get out of the office for one day and shake your routine up, just a little bit, to get a little bit more energy,
because doing the same thing over and over and over and over and over again doesn't lead to creativity...
or happiness.
So sometime this week, go and get out of the office and work from somewhere else.
Believe!
Like this video. Leave a comment. Click on my face, subscribe to the channel.
I'll see you soon!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community